hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play tenebrous lake there are
things oh that's a spider turn the box
oh who hates spiders in this game
oh my spiders in real life it's a spider
this game always no good no good all
right so we got a key to a secret oh
[ __ ] you
huh-huh tinderboxes I've no idea where
I'm going I'm trying to find the Easter
egg cuz I got the key the Easter egg key
but you need to find the door so I don't
know I can like down these stairs double
check with everything
nothing was behind a box or something
okay alright okay
not enough that's a different noise okay
we're we're good we're good we're good
guys we're good we're so good at games
and stuff ah you better leave the miners
alone avoid countenance and why is that
they are not exactly whole interior
workers if you understand what I mean ah
when can you wink wink wink a little
slave labor so where's this so-called
Easter day there was another way I want
to see a flake if I go the other way
this one obviously is a way to progress
a story but if there's another way I
kind of want to find a tinderbox missed
you aw yeah
these are giving me plenty of these now
to nine okay hello
this area spider fine our fighter who's
in here who be banging who be banging ha
fighter attack me who's a docile spider
screw you Spidey anyway rap failure ah
can hurt me oh you don't matter
I'm fine no fu ah oh look at all oh my
goodness a container I recently finished
my experiment with the liquid acid
there's all audacity liquid else it just
by mixing water with some other
chemicals letter told me that I have
been looking for a new way of torturing
people I think my latest project they
can please reminder I start that liquid
acid in the lower part of the stone
connected the barrels of Mead the
barrels labeled as sedum aqua right
really good you need to be in there
spiders anything in there behind here
huh what was it nothing didn't think so
ooh nice shot oh the sunlight okay yay
yay I say ah nope
ah nope mm-hmm not having Danny boxers
oh yeah awesome any other soap big nope
ow my face who's in here
oil yay oil need well Dan the boxers oh
yeah down there I can stack a boxing it
go I don't feel like doing that right
now
oh this goes down here oh let me lay I
thought oh no light at all what huh
remember this dress it looks like it had
been violently torn off oh yeah big no
why did I come down here a lady just
that was it
meat oh this is ah this is where he
stored the liquid acid okay you mean me
ah hurry out is it a Saddam bow
I need to do I need like a hammer or
something to get it out of there
probably bbbbb okay all right over here
Oh art in the box oh yeah oh yeah
so I need to find somewhere that hammers
go a spider
god save again pink yeah I feel so safe
now let me go down in this dish wait I
need to waste the oil here is we are in
the clear
let's all go out and get some beer maybe
haunted hmm what's with all the boxes
being stacked up there's something
behind there some secret secret secret
no the Easter egg is okay oh really
I got a oh man that's got to forever
holy crap that's gonna take forever
Oh God oh my lord
ahh oh goodness gracious
there's no way that's gonna work
everything I accidentally made
everything all haphazard came out
haphazardly their ladders way up there I
mean way up there I would say ever I'm
gonna run out of oil before I get there
I'd know ah gosh you shut up oh don't
know that [ __ ] because this is
understand I need a better for face
their lights could I please have some
lights that I could light on fire
you know how lights work fine let's just
try to be quick about it
I'll be quick maybe work in the dark a
bit or maybe cheat and turn up the gamma
like wicked high yeah coats it ahaha i
cheating i cheating this me cheat a
cheat
hardcore cuz I want to get up there I
would run out of oil dollar times this
might be a secret or the easter egg or I
don't know nope don't fall don't fall
don't tip - don't be tipping okay [ __ ]
get up on that then maybe I could get up
higher try it try it there like that Oh
God
no stupid barrels lucky barrels barrels
are oblong don't deserve to be quick
normally no no no no no you son of a
[ __ ] you son of a mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck a 10 billion [ __ ] oh you
son of a [ __ ] your mother I hate you
oh yeah ah ah good enough huh oh yes I'm
so close not even really a little bit
okay I'm starting over this is [ __ ]
with his stupid bases and unevenness not
gonna work not gonna work need better
barrels all barrels muscle go away while
the boxes can stay
god damn plunk and oh good out of here
organized barrel to [ __ ] out of here
that there keep stacking it up get
straight there we go not even close
what whatever yes I don't care oh yeah I
remembered I don't care about that you
mother [ __ ] get piece of garbage
nothing but dirt lower than dirt no your
clay
are you doing be spazzing
don't be spazzing out I don't need it ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha [ __ ] it
ah [ __ ] I don't care if that's an
easter egg it's not worth it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that not worth it
I don't care that's I don't care yeah
God mother yeah I care about that
[ __ ] it's [ __ ]
the only thing down here it's black hole
shove my foot up it what hole I need a
better face-to-face man get in it
wide stance yeah oh that's yeah that's
exactly what I want yeah totes man oh
it's box jackin nightmare from hell this
part of the gate is this part is this if
this isn't like an Easter Egger is this
like the only other thing to do get son
of a fast was my journal say nothing
it says dick doodlee get over there I
swear you don't get straight good
what get right yeah shut up
enough enough for you more it straight
there that's good stay that way yeah
work it work it baby get it oh yeah
that's all it's so good just like that
and then there and then I get up and
then I get up and then I hop on this
nothing jump high I could get it turned
down the gamma there's a way to I there
we go that's pretty low there we go hey
I did it
yay what was the point all right yeah
yeah I did it oh yeah oh down into the
dark now my legs went up my arse at with
Sandy's like bright grey low fuel lot it
up there
yeah box okay so that was fun and
adventurous and there's nothing else
here for me and oh right here is Sun
okay I'll get down this way
in the next part because I'm all out of
time so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye